SCP-682 Vs SCP-3108.
The Hard to Destroy Reptile may treat all
regular firearms like mere annoyances, but
could the legendary Nerfing Gun take the monster
down a peg or two?
The Nerfing Gun has the power to turn anything
it shoots into a worse version of itself.
A D-Class was ordered to shoot 682 with it,
and after missing six times due to fear, he
landed the lucky seventh shot.
But it wasn’t so lucky.
682 became larger, stronger, and developed
the ability to explode and reconstitute itself
immediately as an offensive weapon.
It breached containment and killed many members
of personnel.
Researcher Westrin theorized that 682 became
a more dangerous version of itself because
a weaker, more docile version of 682 would
be considered a net positive by the SCP Foundation,
and therefore wouldn’t technically be making
it worse.
That’s one dangerous technicality.